[Music]
[Applause]
let's bring in Ross Dinger Yahoo sports
senior writer did a great job covering
the Jim Harbaugh situation there uh the
four top teams came out last night no
real surprise Ross let me start with
chaos what is chaos this weekend in your
opinion H well there are some pretty
chaotic like nightmare scenarios right
and we we're we're I think in the past
like the last 10 years or so of cfp
we've never enter a weekend like this
right where we have a undefeated team
from four five undefeated teams right
from four different conferences so I
think chaos would probably be um Alabama
upsetting Georgia that would that would
certainly start the chaos uh because
then the committee would be tasked with
do you leave out and SEC Champion uh do
you leave out the two-time reigning
National Champion that had won n 29
straight games or and do you leave out
the SEC that's won 13 of the last 17 so
it probably starts there um if Alabama
upsets Georgia and then I think if you
have a couple of other upsets it's kind
of this somewhat nightmare scenario
right like if you if you have um Oregon
you know beat and you've got a one loss
Oregon and you've got a one loss Alabama
and you got a one loss Texas all
fighting for like one or or maybe two
spots that could be pretty wild feelings
are going to or opinions are going to
matter it used to be with the top two
teams it would just be the computers
would say these are the two top teams
now the committee has to look at Florida
State and they have to have an opinion
on Florida State moving if Florida State
wins no matter who their quarterback is
is Florida State going to be in the
final
four
yes uh I know that that is a Hot Topic
um I would be be shocked if a power five
undefeated conference Champion is left
out of the cfp when there is room right
when because and there's going to be
room right because every League doesn't
have an undefeated team right now we
only have four Leagues with an
undefeated team to U so you've got room
for it so I would be I would be shocked
now will they take it under consider
ation and will they will they drop
Florida State as a four seed and
actually have as a three seed
potentially a one loss team so could a
one loss conference Champion be a three
seed over four seed Florida State I
think that's the biggest question
because I think Florida state is in I I
just would be would be blown away if the
committee left them out as an undefeated
power five Champion how would we feel
next year at this time with this current
scenario yeah it would be uh well it
would be it's funny I'm writing a story
on that right now about conference
Championship games in their future um
Dan and and do we need them in an
expanded playoff era plenty of people
think we don't um and one of the reasons
why is this year for
instance uh all but three of the teams
competing in a in a conference
Championship Game would be in the
playoff right now you know before the
championship games ok State could play
their way in right by beating Texas uh
Louisville could probably you know play
their way in by beating Florida State in
Iowa of course uh could play its way in
um by beating Michigan some some might
say Iowa would already be in some might
say Louisville would already be in so
you could have almost all of the teams
participating this weekend in a
conference Championship game all of
those teams in an expanded playoff field
could be in except maybe one or two um
and that's why I think there's a real
question uh going forward now what makes
Conference Championship Games exciting
in an expanded playoff field is you're
basically playing for a buy right you're
playing for a first round buy so there's
you know only only the conference
champions the top four Conference
champions in an expanded field will get
a a first round buy so you got to win
your conference Championship to have uh
to be able to get a a first round by in
the playoff in two years time is Ryan
Day more likely to be at Ohio State or
Jim Harbaugh still at
Michigan um I would probably say Ryan
day at Ohio State uh you know I think
it's it's it's difficult um for for me
to see Jim Harbaugh coming coming back
as coach uh not to say it won't happen
um you know the last two years will it
be his decision or somebody else's
decision yeah I think it would be his
decision um I Michigan seems quite on
board and in support of Jim Harbaugh uh
and so I would I would be surprised if
they would make that decision so I think
it would be his decision and Dan you
know the last two years we've seen Jim
Harbaugh flirt with NFL jobs right
interviewed for a few maybe even thought
he was going to be offered that Vikings
job and leave so this year he's got a
third straight right really good
football team um I would imagine that
there's there's maybe a place for him in
the NFL but if there isn't maybe he ends
up back in Michigan reality is set in in
Colorado with
Dion as we move forward he just lost his
defensive coordinator they don't have
oil money there Dion saying we're not an
ATM um what is what is the uh future for
Colorado let let's look at for next year
because he's got some decommits here um
what do you think the uh future looks
like well this day this era in in
college football you can um you can have
whoever at head coach Dan but you need
nil right you need nil money you need a
collective uh that has I don't know at
least three million to spend a year on a
football roster maybe five million um on
a football roster and if you if you
don't have that you're going to be in uh
you know you're not going to get the
kind of players that you want and and I
think Dion kind of mentioned that right
he's kind of suggested that the the
Colorado needs to step up when it comes
to when it comes to nil um so you look
forward at Colorado and they certainly
need to to do that right they need to
invest in nil invest in their roster uh
but you know it you wonder if the Dion
thing is a like a flash in the pan is
this going to be consistent can he keep
keep it up sort of thing and build on
what happened earlier this past season
um I think a lot of people hope that the
season this year for Colorado is not a
microcosm right for for Dion overall um
where you boom right out of the Gates
Right fiery and flashy and all this
attention and then man you just can't
finish games they probably should have
should have won three or four games uh
during that losing streak and they just
couldn't finish and then of course they
got the injury situation but you know
also Dion kind of seemed to make a a
panic move in the middle of the Season
by kind of demoting his offensive
coordinator who's now has left for a
head coaching job at San Diego State
Shawn Lewis that was that was a weird
one uh it was it was an odd decision so
uh everybody's certainly watching
Boulder to see what happens in year two
with on good to visit with you Ross
continue great work thanks for joining
us thanks Dan Ross Dinger you who Sports
senior writer yes I uh had him as the
defensive coordinator ver the offensive
coordinator who has left Dion and then